Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update if you're having trouble deciding
whether to spend your five hundred
dollars on an xbox one or a ps4 consider
this new entry on the market a
high-quality all aluminum Nintendo
Entertainment System hey least it's got
exclusives analog interactive makers of
this beautiful walnut Neo Geo are now
accepting pre-orders for their latest
product they call the analog NT an NES
reengineered with high quality parts but
with the original nes cpu and PP you
they claim that it isn't an emulator but
more like a really nice nes there are
several modern features including high
quality audio wiring so the audio is
crystal clear and it includes a Famicom
expansion port so you can use all your
peripherals from the NES zapper to the
famicom disk system you can even get it
in a different color for an extra 50
bucks and you can buy an hdmi adapter to
get an upscaled HD output the HDMI
adapter can even add optional scan lines
to the image for that retro look they
aren't selling any new fangled
controllers however you can order new or
refurbished original NES controllers or
one of these super slick refurbished
Famicom controllers of course for 500
bucks you can get just about anything in
console gaming including a next-gen
system or like a dozen flea market nes
systems but hey this kind of slick thing
is in your wheelhouse want it to go for
it and stick around on gamespot com
because it's video game history month we
got a lot of coverage on that retro
stuff that you seem to like so much